[Musik]
alles an dieser Stadt ist
atememberaubend ihre
Dimensionen ihre Gegensätze ihr
quirliges
durcheinander Lagos nur zu überblicken
am Tag weltberühmt für sein
Nachtleben har arbeiten noch Herter
spielen das
isters mit geschätzt 80 Millionen
Einwohner vielleicht bald so groß wie
Deutschland jeden Tag kommen neue
Menschen nach Lagos jeden Tag denn in
Lagos liegt das
Geld nirgendwo sonst in Afrika prallen
die extreme so sehr
aufeinander wenn du in Lagos überleben
willst musst du dich auf der Straße
auskennen sonst nehmen sie Dich nicht
ernst und machen dich
fertig wir tauchen ein in die Mega City
und treffen Menschen die uns mitnehmen
in die Metropole der
[Musik]
extreme
die Nacht birgt Geheimnisse und sie ist
voller
Verführungen im secrets Palace ist heute
superstrip bow nirgends ist das pralle
Leben so zu Hause wie in Lagos
Nachtclub der Club Tycoon pretty m of
Lagos ist auch schon da und von uns
schnell etwas abgelehnt
[Musik]
der schöne Mike der auch in Immobilien
investiert ist so wie seine Stadt selbst
großzügig mit allem Alkohol Sex und
Spaß das Land ist kein Land wo es
Golfplätze und Pferderennen gibt und
solche Arten von Aktivitäten um Spaß zu
haben die einzige Art von Spaß die wir
hier haben ist das Nachtleben die
Unterhaltungsindustrie und der afrobats
der sich weltweit verbreitet hat
da ist ein Hunger in diesem Umfeld der
beste zu werden und das sieht man dann
überall auf der
Welt die Lautstärke im Club ist
permanent am Anschlag mit jeder Stunde
die vergeht wird die Show schneller und
schriller Whisky und Kognak werden nur
flaschenweise serviert aufwärts bis zu
1000 tatsächlich wird in Lagos
chagner getrunken wie nirgend sonst auf
der Welt die Zahl der Millionäre steigt
ständig es ist wie ein Tanz auf dem
Vulkan hemmungslos atemlos
alterslos wie H du das aus sorry aber
ich meine wir werden alle älter nein
nein nein das gefällt mir das Alter ist
kein Faktor für einen Lebensstil der
Spaß
macht ich sage den Leuten immer es ist
eine Sache des Geistes selbst
die Jacksons in ihrem Alter treiben es
immer noch bunt und haben wahrscheinlich
immer noch mehr Spaß als die
jüngeren es ist also eine Sache des
Geistes ich habe mich nie in einem
bestimmten Alter gesehen ja wir werden
reifer wir denken anders wir wollen
anderes wir wollen dass die Dinge anders
laufen aber weißt du was ich glaube man
muss sich immer wieder anstrengen
egal in welcher Branche man tätig ist
wenn man zulässt dass das Alter zur
Karriere wird kann man genauso gut nach
Hause gehen und sich zur Ruhe
setzen der schöne Mike will uns noch
einmal treffen und wir ihn auch wer
Menschen wie ihn in Lagos kennt der ist
drin wer nicht der bleibt draußen meist
sein Leben
lang Lagos gehört zu den reichsten
Städten Afrikas Millionen Menschen aber
leben in Armut die Dimension ihrer
Trostlosigkeit zeigt sich nur am Tag
manche Menschen nennen makoku das
Venedig Afrikas doch die
Hunderttausenden schäbigen Bretterbuden
haben so gar nichts mit den Palazzi der
italienischen Lagunenstadt
gemein makoko das ist bittere Armut und
einer der schlimmsten Slams des
Kontinents wie viele Menschen genau hier
leben weiß niemand für Außenstehende
wirkt makoko die Insel mit dem
idylischen Namen wie die
Apokalypse die Häuser durchzogen vom
brackigen Wasser der Lagune Müll
Exkremente und
mittendrin schwimmen die
Kinder die meisten Menschen sind
einfache Fischer wie Bano Kok sein zu
Hause ein ärmlich
Holzverschlag hier lebt er mit seiner
ersten Frau und ihren zwei Kindern es
ist der tägliche Überlebenskampf von
Menschen die nie eine echte Chance
[Musik]
hatten als Kind bin ich meinem Vater
aufs Meer gefolgt mein Vater hatte vier
Kinder und schickte drei zur Schule aber
ich sollte ihm beim Fischen helfen als
ich Heirat verlangte mein Vater dass ich
weggehe er gab mir ein Boot mit Motor
und als meine Kinder zur Welt kam wurde
mir erst klar wie hart es ist wenn man
für sich selbst sorgen
muss weil Sonntag ist und seine Frau
heute nebenbei als Friseurin Geld
verdient kauft der 2jährige eine warme
Mahlzeit bei einer der vielen
Garküchen für die Familie ein kleiner
Luxus banuso kokbe hat noch eine zweite
Frau und mit ihr ein Baby in Nigeria
sind mehrere enen erlaubt der Vater
entscheidet jeden Tag nach seinen
Einnahmen ob seine Kinder zur Schule
gehen oder nicht meist aber bleiben sie
zu
Hause es ist nicht einfach für zwei
Frauen zu sorgen wenn ich auf dem Meer
bin manchmal gehe ich Fischen fange aber
nicht viel dann verdiene ich vielleicht
6 do$ und jede Frau bekommt etwa ein
Dollar
davon das größte Problem aber sind die
Kinder und sie zur Schule zu schicken
ich gehe Fischen aber verdiene manchmal
nicht genug
dafür der steigende Meeresspiegel erhöht
das flutrisiko in makoko schon jetzt
stehen Teile der Baracken unter Wasser
hunderttausende würden ihr zu Hause
verlieren wo sollen sie dann
hin es ist kurz vor 6 Uhr abends die
Dunkelheit bricht herein und über makoko
liegt der beißende Qualm der vielen
kleinen
fischräucherin gerade ist mal wieder der
Strom ausgefallen wir kommen noch einmal
wieder um mit banuso kokbe nachts auf
Fischfang zu
gehen etwa 25 Millionen Menschen leben
in Lagos Schätzungen eine genaue Zahl
gibt es nicht die nigerianische Mega
City wird auch das größte
Flüchtlingslager der Welt genannt denn
die meisten fliehen hierher vor dem
Terror im Rest des
Landes wir sind verabredet mit einem der
auch mal Arm war der influenzer money
aber hat es in der Metropole der extreme
geschafft hey Leute aus aller Welt ich
bin white money auch bekannt als Gold
money euer guter Freund heute abend habe
ich drei
Events heute alles in schwarz
Rollkragenpullover
Lederhose
[Musik]
Lederjacke ich will mein Haar bedecken
ich will genauso aussehen wie
hier
amot liegen parat heute ist schwarz
angesagt money
bürgerlichel hat Big Brother Nigeria
gewonnen seitdem ist er ein Star mit
über 2 Millionen Followern auf
Instagram die Mega City Lagos war gut
zuos ist eineestle City verstehst du es
istle die
meistenesellchachen mus um werden du
sagst etwas es kommt ins Internet und
zack bist du eine internetsensation
berühmt zu werden ist einfach in Nigeria
aber berühmt zu bleiben das ist das
Problem image ist alles in Lagos 300 000
hat ih seine Maibach Limousine
gekostet Extras wie 100te blaue
ledlichter im Innenraum
inklusive
bluchen wir ein in die Nacht es geht
nicht ums kleckern es geht ums
klotzen es gibt zwei Sorten von Typen
die die Geld haben und es auch ausgeben
und die die Geld haben und es nicht
ausgeben die haben immer Angst dir Geld
auszugeben wenn Gott mich zu einem
Milliardär macht dann kannst du mir das
ansehen ich würde das Geld ausgeben ich
warte auf
niemanden
Leben ist jetzt und jetzt ist white
money ein VIP Big Brother ein
bigstar einer der es geschafft hat und
bei den ganz Großen mitspielen
[Musik]
darf heute Abend werden die African
Movie Awards verlien ganzlywood Nigeria
Filmindustrie ist aufmarschiert und der
32-Jährige
mittendrin Events gehören zu seinem
Geschäft viele Klickzahlen befeuern
es eine schillernde Karriere in der
megaity die sich den erfolgreichen so
gerne zu Füßen
legt der nächste Termin ruft inzwischen
ist es Mitternacht ein influencer darf
nicht ruhen Geschwindigkeit gehört zum
Business ein kleines Bewerbungsvideo für
das Containerformat hat white money groß
gemacht der Weg zum Erfolg war nicht
immer
einfach ich kann nicht über Armut
nachdenken mein ganzes Leben war Armut
da gibt es auch nichts zu
beschönigen ehlich gesag in meinemten du
nicht sein
wollen es geht weiter durch die Nacht
das nächste Event eine Stunde entfernt
vor seiner Karriere hatte white money
einen kleinen straßenshop er hat das
nicht vergessen sondern mitgenommen in
sein neues Leben als
influencer es sind vor allem die
Menschen auf der Straße die für ihn
gevotet haben der
32jährige genießt sein neues Leben in
vollen
Zügen das ist das was ich liebe die
Menschen passen sich meiner Rolle an
meinem Style für mich gibt es keinen
Wettbewerb es ist Lifestyle Freiheit
sich selbst zu mögen und das ist es was
ich
mache 40 Jahre von jetzt da werde ich
vielleicht in Rente sein und mein Geld
genießen aber jetzt bin ich voll aktiv
aktiv aktiv ad dem aktiv aktiv dem
aktiv Lagos die Stadt der Extreme die
Stadt von Glitzer und klemmmer und die
in der Millionen von der Hand in den
Mund leben und doch irgendwie ihren
Alltag meistern
müssen während in den mänen Clubs noch
gefeiert wird macht sich 53 km weiter
und immer noch in der Mega City Lagos
amakukuzor auf den Weg zur Arbeit mehr
als eine kleine Wohnung weit außerhalb
kann sich die jungköchin in einem fün
Sterne Hotel nicht
leisten um 4 Uhr morgens steigt sie in
den hoteltransport der immer wieder neue
Kollegen aufnimmt die alleinerziehende
Mutter übernimmt meist die
Morgenschicht ich habe keine Wahl ich
muss das
machen vielleicht kann ich mich spter
damit beschäftigen näher zu meiner
Arbeit zu
ziehen wenn ich näher hinziehe muss ich
aber darüber nachdenken dass meine
Töchter die Schule wechseln
müssen die Schulen in besseren Vierteln
sind anders die Gebühren teurer und
alles andere
auch aber ich muss bald was ändern damit
ich einfach weniger Stress
habe so viele müde Menschen die so hart
darum kämpfen im molloch Lagos zu
überleben und sich für ihre Kinder eine
bessere Zukunft
erhoffen die Grenze ihrer Belastbarkeit
so sagt die 34-Jährige habe sie schon
oft erreicht doch für ihre kleine
Familie müsse sie all das auf sich
[Musik]
nehmen ich darf das nicht zeigen ich
muss stark sein für mich und meine
Kinder die Mädchen sind so klein
manchmal wünschte ich mir ich könnte von
meinem zause an einen besseren Ort
ziehen aber ich arbeite daran
[Musik]
8 Stunden am Tag dauert die Schicht der
jungköchenin in einem
Luxushotel dafür bekommt sie am Ende des
Monats etwa 250 € schon die Miete kostet
50 € dazu die
Schulgebühren der krasse Gegensatz
zwischen dem was sie ihr Motel und auf
den Straßen von Lagos sieht geht ihr oft
nahe es ist nicht einfach denn manchmal
wenn wir Reste haben und ich sehe dass
wir Lebensmittel wegwerfen tut mir das
leid es tut mir so leid denn es gibt
viele Menschen die kein Wasser zum
Trinken haben und dann frage ich mich
warum verschwenden wir all diese
Lebensmittel aber wir müssen die
Firmenpolitik befolgen die Menschen da
draußen tun mir wirklich
leid die alleinerziehende Mutter ist
dankbar für ihren Job der feste Vertrag
bei einem internationalen Arbeitgeber
ist für sie schon eine große
Chance jeden Tag wache ich morgens auf
gehe zur Arbeit und komme abends wieder
nach Hause dafür kann ich dankbar sein
denn viele Menschen die früh morgens
aufstehen sehen ihre Familie nicht sehen
ihre Kinder nicht sehen ihren Mann nicht
sehen ihre Frauen nicht das ist also
etwas wofür man wirklich dankbar sein
[Musik]
kann dankbar für einen Job in der Küche
während Millionen Menschen im
straßengewrr von Lagos auf irgendeinen
kleinen Job hoffen auch in der
Nacht so wie Mary 29 ihren richtigen
Namen sollen wir nicht nennen denn ihre
Familie weiß nicht womit sie ihr Geld
verdient mary ist auf der Suche nach
Freiern ihren Job bei der Bank hat sie
während Corona verloren schafft sie an
jeden Abend auf den Straßen der
meacity es ist auf jeden Fall eine Menge
Risiko dabei es ist nicht so süß es ist
nicht so rosig es birgt eine Menge
Gefahren in sich weißt du wenn du jetzt
nachts jemanden hast der dich nur für
eine Nacht haben will einen Fremden
jemanden den du nicht kennst da kann
alles Mögliche passieren die Mädchen
haben auf der Straße viel erlebt aber
wir danken Gott wir machen weiter und
hoffen auf Besserung wenn man keine
Hilfe von irgendwoher hat keinen Vater
keine Mutter keine Schwester muss man
sein Leben selbst in die Hand nehmen und
leben in ihrer Heimat im Norden Nigerias
tobt der Terror ihr Bruder und ihr Vater
sind tot die senjährige Tochter lebt bei
der Großmutter Marys Leben ist ein
einsames wie so viele Leben in Lagos es
ist schwierig für eine Frau sich allein
hier
durchzuschlagen es gibt viele die ihr
geldlor
dere gorben sind aber das willst du
nicht wissen man muss sehr vorsichtig
sein sehr sehr klug es liegt nicht in
unserer Macht aber man muss einfach sehr
wachsam sein es passieren viele Dinge
wenn du aber wachsam bist wird Gott dir
helfen 35 € in der Nacht das ist Marys
Verdienst wenn es gut läuft die Angst
aber sich mit einer Krankheit
anzustecken oder überfallen zu werden
schwingt immer
mit der höchsten Kriminalitätsraten
weltweit Raubüberfälle Morde die
kidnappingindustrie blüht jeder entführt
jeden Nachbarn ihre Nachbarn Kinder ihre
Eltern wo Millionen Menschen unterhalb
der Armutsgrenze leben zählt jeder Cent
ist das Leben
erbarmungslos in einer Stadt außer
Kontrolle sorgen sie nachts aber auch
tagsüber immerhin für ein wenig Ordnung
die Area Boys sie gehören zu Lagos wie
die Lagune ihr Auftreten ist Teil ihres
Geschäftsmodells laut bedrohlich und
immer in
Gangs sie leben von Trinkgeldern dafür
managen sie den Verkehr bewachen Autos
sorgen in beinah jedem Stadtviertel für
eine scheinbare
Sicherheit wir kämpfen nicht aber klar
kommt der Kampf auch mal zu uns
wir regeln das eigentlich friedlich aber
wenn ein Kampf
kommt also wenn ich etwa aus Versehen
auf dich trete dann entschuldige ich
mich aber wenn du kämpfen willst bin ich
bereit ich bin ein Straßenjunge und wenn
wir unaufmerksam sind verlieren wir wir
Jungs aus der Gegend wenn wir nicht
aufpassen verlieren wir wenn du mich
verarschst dann reagieren wir so ist das
hier der Kameramann Gago ideb genannt
bischop ist mit den area Boys in seinem
Viertel ojadu Burger inzwischen
befreundet sein Film über die street
gangs in Lagos hat es sogar bei Netflix
geschafft lange hat auch bischop
geglaubt dass die Jungs gefährlich sind
dass er ihnen nicht trauen kann die
monatelangen Vorbereitungen für seinen
Film waren für ihn eine neue
[Musik]
Erfahrung du triffst diese Jungs du
redest mit ihnen du setzt dich mit Ihnen
zusammen du rauchst mit ihnen du trinkst
was sie trinken und weißt du sie fühlen
sich sehr entspannt sie urteilen nicht
über dich du verurteilst sie nicht du
behandelst sie nicht auf einem
niedrigeren Niveau du bist mit Ihnen
zusammen und merkst dass es ganz
natürlich ist dass die Menschen sich
austauschen die Leute fangen an sich mit
dir vertraut zu
fühlen nach Lagos kam der 39-Jährige nur
mit einem Rucksack zwei Hosen und ein
Paar
Schuhen Plan einer der großen in
nolywood der nigerianischen
Filmindustrie zu werden auch sein Film
über die Area Boys hat ihm dabei
geholfen wenn man mit diesen Leuten zu
tun hat merkt man dass einige von ihnen
nicht einfach absichtlich rausgehen
aufwachsen und auf der Straße sitzen
wollen die Umstände man versteht dass
auch diese Menschen Hoffnungen und
Wünsche hatten aber irgendwie ist etwas
zerbrochen und sie sind dort gelandet
also ja ich wünsche Ihnen dass Sie ETW
besseres erfahren ich wünschte sie
hätten du weißt schon sie hätten eine
bessere
Chance Volum irobudo hatte auch auf
seine Chance
gehofft als junger Mann kam er nach
Lagos er hatte eine Schule besucht war
künstlerisch begabt das Leben aber
meinte es anders und er landete als
auf der
Straße in seinem winzigen zu Hause malt
er sich in eine andere Welt manchmal
verkauft eines seiner Bilder doch Lagos
war nicht gut zu
ihm Lagos macht dich einfach kaputt es
ist nicht wirklich sanft es behandelt
Menschen wie uns als dritte Klasse und
abgesehen davon dass wir zur dritten
Klasse gehören sind wir die dritten in
der dritten
Klasse zwischen Highways und
Umspannwerk Kilom entfernt von den men
Clubs haben sich Menschen wie Volum
eingerichtet erst vor kurzem hat die
Stadt wieder einmal ihre ärmlichen
Baracken abgerissen sie werden sie
wieder aufbauen wo sollen sie auch hin
überall liegt Müll durch den Ziegen und
Kinder
[Musik]
streunen der Platz an dem der 9jährige
am liebsten Malt ist für ihn schon die
reinste
idülle
ein bisschen Grün kaum sichtbar ein
kleiner
Bach heute malt er an einem Auftrag für
einen
Stripclub ein paar tausend Naira
vielleicht 4 für seine Freundin und die
zwei
[Musik]
Töchter ich möchte nicht dass Sie ein
solches Leben führen müssen wie ich es
jetzt tue das ist der Hauptgrund warum
ich sie aufs Land geschickt habe das
Zuhause in dem wir offiziell wohnten
wurde zerstört ich habe meiner Frau
gesagt okay
wir können es uns nicht leisten zusammen
aufs Land zu gehen und dort zu bleiben
ich bleibe in der Stadt und ihr geht
zurück aufs
Land volume will uns noch einmal
mitnehmen nachts zum Platz der Plätze
der Seele von
Lagos jetzt müssen wir erst einmal
wieder zurück ins 20 km entfernte
makoko in dem lagunenlam bricht bei
unsere Ankunft die Dämmerung herein
gleich brennen hier nur noch ein paar
Lichter die Menschen gehen Hause or es
vollens dunkel
wird Joel hungbo kämpft mal wieder mit
den Widrigkeiten des
Slams in seinem kleinen Laden verkauft
der DVDs Handy Zubehör und
Strom für ein paar nairer können seine
Nachbarn hier ihre Telefone Aufladen
denn der 32-Jährige besitzt immerhin ein
Generator nebenan Räuchern ein Fischer
und seine Frau den Fang des Tages die
Ausbeute war heute einmal
gut Joel liebt diese Abende wenn es
friedlich ist und langsam Ruhe
einkehrt das Leben in makoko ist
überhaupt nicht
schwer wir sind sehr freundliche
Menschen wir sind
glücklich manchmal kann es zu Gewalt
kommen aber sag mir eine Gegend wo es
keine Gewalt gibt wenn wir streiten dann
einigen wir uns auch wieder das Leben
ist nicht schwer in
makoko mit Einbruch der Dunkelheit
versammelt sich die Nachbarschaft vor
Joels
minishop dann zeigt der vierfache Vater
Filme aus aller Welt viel Nollywood aber
auch chinesische oder us blockbustter
ich zeige die Filme damit die Kinder
sehen dass das Leben nicht nur hier
stattfindet wo sie leben sonst werden ja
nur lokale Filme gezeigt wenn ich andere
Filme zeige ändert sich ihre Wahrnehmung
des Lebens im Allgemeinen und so ist es
auch ich zeige die Filme aus Spaß damit
Sie sehen wie das Leben in anderen
Ländern
ist sie träumen von der Gren Welt dabei
ist ihnen schon das prale Leben der Mega
City
[Musik]
verschlossen wir verlassen makoko und
fahren zur Insel der Sieger nur 15
Minuten
entfernt auf Victoria Island wird der
Strom rausgeblasen als ob es kein
die Reichen und Schönen sie treffen sich
im vanity
Club Partytime mit pretty Mike of Lagos
so richtig los geht es erst um
Mitternacht wer hierher kommt hat Spaß
daran sich zu präsentieren alles ist so
wie Lagos nun mal ist
[Musik]
extrem musstt komm du musst direkt
kommen du musst heiß kommen wir mögen
Authentizität in Lagos geht es um
Originalität wir kennen unechte Ärsche
wenn wir sie sehen darf ich falscher
Arsch im Fernsehen sagen wirkennen einen
falschen Arsch wenn wir dich sehen du
kommst authentisch du kommst korrekt und
bist bereit zu liefern das ist das worum
es in Lagos geht Arbeit und Spiel hart
arbeiten noch härter spielen das ist
Lagos
Baby natürlich ist der gota des
Nachtlebens immer dai pretty Lagos
posiert und wartet darauf was die Nacht
so bringen wird wo er ist sind die
Frauen nicht weit irgendwann so sagt er
habe er aufgehört sie zu
zählen ich glaube uns fällt immer eine
Gelegenheit ein um zu feiern wir nutzen
jede Gelegenheit die sich uns bietet um
zuzen zu feiern die zu nutzen die uns
das Leben gegeben
hat wenn sich Chancen ergeben ergreifen
wir sie auch wir sind ein Land in dem
die Menschen gerne feiern und Spaß
haben so richtig Spaß hat der schöne
Mike heute Abend allerdings nicht und
auch im Club will keine rechte Stimmung
aufkommen das feierolk ist feiermüde wer
nur das Luxusleben kennt ist auch mal
gelangweilt morgen ist ein neuer
Tag langeweile kennen sie in makoko
nicht jeder Tag jede Nacht ist ein Kampf
ums Überleben hinter dem
vollbeleuchteten Highway der sich durch
die Lagune schlängelt Leben
hunderttausende in
Dunkelheit der Fischer banuso kokbe ist
mit Nachbarn hinausgefahren es beginnt
zu
regnen mit einer einfachen langen
Fangleine zieht er ein paar kleine
Fische aus dem Wasser seit erlebt der
Slam makuku eine
Bevölkerungsexplosion und damit auch
einen Kampf um die Ware
Fisch als wir anfingen zum Meer zu
fahren haben wir viele Fische gefangen
aber seit wir hier einen
Bevölkerungsanstieg erleben und alle in
diesem einen Meer fallen aufstellen gibt
es nicht mehr genug Fische
mehr Z Kinder pro Familie sind keine
Seltenheit die meisten leben von der
Hand in den
Mund busos Kollege versucht es noch
einmal mit seinem Netz das Ergebnis aber
ist ähnlich
armselig makuko ist trotz allem ihr zu
Hause doch wie lange wird es das noch
sein wenn ich aufwache habe ich Angst
davor dass ich kein Geld habe und dass
die Regierung kommen könnte um uns alle
von hier wegzujagen und wenn das
passiert wohin soll ich dann mit meinen
Frauen und Kindern ziehen das ist das
was mir Angst macht wenn ich
aufwache makuko ist die einzige Heimat
die banusu und seine Familie haben sie
gibt ihnen Geborgenheit auch wenn sie
auf der Schattenseite der Metropole
Leben 3000 Menschen ziehen jeden Tag
nach
Lagos bis Ende des Jahrhunderts soll sie
mit 80 Millionen Einwohnern die größte
Stadt der Welt
sein die Stadt wächst völlig außer
Kontrolle Stunden um Stunden verbringen
die Menschen im Stau atmen den Dreck der
Mega City kämpfen um
Wohnraum dorineelen Koko hat den Kampf
vorerst
verloren sie nimmt uns mit in Ihre
Community oder besser in das was davon
übrig geblieben
ist über Nacht haben Bagger ihr Haus und
die ihrer Nachbarn
abgerissen hunderte wurden
obdachlos weil der Stadtteil on Schui
nicht weit vom mondänen Victoria Island
liegt verfolgt die Stadt ganz eigene
Pläne
[Musik]
wir haben nicht viel wir haben das hier
gekauft und unsere Häuser gebaut nur das
Wenige was wir besitzen um unseren Kopf
zu betten und jetzt reißen sie es ab
weil sie es an reiche Leute verkaufen
wollen aber wir sind alle Nigerianer das
geht doch nicht dagegen haben wir
Protest
[Musik]
eingelegt die 63-Jährige Witwe hat gegen
den Abriss geklagt das Verfahren läuft
so armselig die kleinen Bretterbuden in
onchuki auch sein mögen sie sind das
zause von mehr als 100.000 Menschen ihr
ganzer Stolz inmitten von all dem Müll
und der Trostlosigkeit auf dem ihre
Hütten gebaut sind dor Coko hat ihre
eigene und die umliegenden Communities
mobilisiert sie wollen sich den Abriss
der sogenannten informal settlements der
kleinen aus dem Boden gestampften
Siedlungen nicht mehr gefallen
lassen
wir fühlen uns traurig allein und falsch
deshalb sind wir vor Gericht gezogen wir
nehmen uns unser Land zurück und unsere
Häuser werden wir wieder aufbauen
niemand kann uns unsere Häuser wegnehmen
lasst die armen atmen ich habe denen
gesagt dass wir alle gleich sind also
müssen Sie uns hier lassen sie wissen
nicht wo sie uns unterbringen können das
ist der Grund warum wir
kämpfen
es ist ein langwieriger Kampf doch die
Frauen wollen sich nicht einfach
geschlagen
geben zwischen Betonbrücken und
Kreuzungen haben Dorine und ihre
Freundinnen der Stadt immerhin ein
kleines Stück Land abgetrotzt inäcken
ziehen Sie hier Melonen Zucchini Tomaten
die sie auf dem Markt verkaufen oder
selbst
verbrauchen
dreimal in der Woche kommen die Frauen
nach dem Job
hierher es ist ihre eigene kleine Oase
im Dschungel der
meacity gemeinsam etwas auf die Beine zu
stellen das hat die Frauen beflügelt ihr
Alltag in Lagos ist hart meist kämpft
jede für sich allein die Gruppe aber
gibt ihnen Energie auch im Kampf um ihr
Eigentum wenn 3000 Menschen täglich neu
in diead ist auch die Versorgung mit
Lebensmitteln ein Problem der Hunger in
Lagos in der ganze Stadtteile so groß
sind wie Berlin ist unersätlich
gehandelt und gegessen wird rund um die
Uhr der Großmarkt von Lagos weit im
Norden der Stadt ernährt sie
alle das Ausmaß von M 12 sprengt jede
Dimension die Mengen an Gemüse Obst und
Gewürzen sind gigantisch allein 600.000
Tonnen Tomaten werden jedes Jahr
verkauft gehandelt wird 24 Stunden an
jedem Tag des
Jahres Nigerianer essen gerne scharf
nicht nur für roten Chili in allen
Variationen Reife und Schärfegraden gibt
es einen eigenen
[Musik]
Sektor fus überblickt im Chaos die
Ordnung jeden Tag muss er für die t
genügend frische Ware
[Musik]
heranschaffen es gibt viele
Herausforderungen in Nigeria die erste
ist das Thema
Sicherheit die meisten Bauern in Nigeria
sind
Kleinbauern sie können ihre Farmen im
Norden nicht bewirtschaften weil dort
Terror und Gewalt
herrschen das ist das eine die zweite
Herausforderung hat mit den Straßen zu
tun die meisten unserer Straßen sind
nicht sicher
unbefestigt und dann müssen wir Händler
und Landwirte dabei unterstützen die
Lebensmittelpreise für alle Bürger auf
einen vernünftiges Niveau zu
bringen 100000 Händler verkaufen ihre
Waren die schon länger auch aus den
Nachbarländern kommen müssen Nigeria
allein schafft es nicht mehr die
Menschen in Lagos zu ernähren jeden
Monat muss die Marktverwaltung die
Liefermengen erhöhen der Preis für Brot
hat sich innerhalb eines Jahres
verschsfacht die Preise galoppieren ein
Korb Tomaten der vielleicht zu einem
Preis von 1000 Nair verkauft wurde
kostet jetzt 20 000
na sie wissen ja dass die
Transportkosten und Benzinpreise
gestiegen sind und wir müssen alle diese
Variablen natürlich berücksichtigen
wir wollen abends noch einmal
wiederkommen wenn all die Waren
angeliefert werden doch dann werden die
Zufahrtsstraßen gesperrt zwei
straßenkehrerinnen wurden ermordet es
gibt Demonstrationen gegen die
Lebensverhältnisse in Lagos die
Sicherheitslage zwingt uns mal 12 zu
verlassen so verabreden wir uns noch
einmal in
makoko irgendwo in dem Gewirre aus
Wasserstraßen treffen wir einen der
gerne im Verborgenen
arbeitet Pastor Joseph wer sich von
Joseph allerdings einen Segen erhofft
der ist bei ihm an der falschen Adresse
joseph ist ein sogenannter yahoooy das
Business des jungen Mannes ist so
einfach wie einträglich er betrügt
verzweifelte Menschen in aller Welt um
Geld sein Gesicht dürfen wir daher nicht
zeigen
ich habe mich wie ein Pastor gekleidet
denn manche Leute glauben an Jesus du
sagst ihnen ein Wunder wird Ihnen helfen
du sagst ihnen sie sollen ein Kapitel in
der Bibel lesen und du gibst ihnen das
Kapitel in dem Jesus ein Wunder
vollbracht hat sie glauben an dich
verstehst du wir sagen Ihnen also dass
wir nicht nur einem einzigen helfen
können und dass man natürlich von der
Hilfe die sie erfahren haben auch etwas
zurückgeben muss und manche schicken uns
dann
Geld
ver werden Scammer wie Joseph in Nigeria
genannt denn ihre Straftat fällt unter
den gesetzartikel
419 seine Mails landen irgendwo auf der
Welt und versprechen Wunderheilung
Menschen die keinen Ausweg Wissen
kontaktieren ihn sein Assistent sucht
während der Gespräche schnell die
passenden Bibelstellen bis zu 300
überweisen Kunden für ihre heiligen
versprechen es ist das anonyme Leben in
makoko das Joseph hier
hält wenn Gott mir sagt ich muss diese
Arbeit aufgeben und etwas Besseres tun
dann soll er mir helfen und mir Wege
zeigen dann werde ich das Leben leben
ich werde ein besseres Leben als dieses
führen weißt du es ist genau wie ich
vorhin gesagt habe die Situation von
Menschen verändert
sich die meisten Kunden von Joseph
kommen aus Kanada und Europa Kontinente
die er nie gesehen hat und doch ist ihm
die Welt in seiner kleinen Baracke ganz
nah von der großen Welt träumt auch der
influencer white money nach einer langen
Nacht muss er heute auch tagsüber
performen der Big Brother Gewinner
Nigeria bastelt unermüdlich an seiner
Karriere wer ihn gut genug bezahlt dem
steht er als Werbefigur zur Verfügung
heute ist es eine Firma für Solarpanels
seine Ankunft gleich der eines
[Applaus]
Popstars er ist von meiner Region inugu
er ist mein Bruder er ist mein Freund
und ich bin hierher gekommen um mit ihm
zu
feiern er ist einer von uns und er ist
in teger er liebt alle und er trägt uns
alle ich liebe ihn
er ist n und er kümmert sich um jeden
ich liebe jeden und ich liebe auch
money die die ihm auf der Straße
zujubeln sind die die bei Big Brother
für ihn gevotet haben die wie einst eher
von der großen Karriere in der Mega City
träumen oder zumindest ein kleines Stück
von seinem Erfolg abhaben
[Musik]
wollen berühmt wurde habe ich in einer
Satellitenstadt gewohnt die meiste Zeit
des Tages gab es keine Elektrizität die
Generatoren haben den ganzen Tag Krach
gemacht und
außerdem haben sie die Luft
[Applaus]
verpästet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der Traum vom großen Glück verwandelt
das graue Viertel auf dem Festland in
eine wogende Partymeile voller
[Applaus]
Lebensfreude mitten am Tag feiern die
Menschen auch das ist
[Musik]
Lagos
je mehr Menschen zu dir kommen und Fotos
wollen desto mehr beweist es dass du zu
ihnen gehörst und das ist einfach Freude
jede celebrity die es nicht mag dass man
Fotos von ihr macht ist nicht bereit
eine celebrity zu sein und ich bin
bereit ich möchte eine celebrity sein
ich liebe es
das Glück liegt in der meac City
manchmal in den einfachen Dingen und
manchmal auch einfach in der
Hoffnung wer das Herz von Lagos sucht
der wird es nur an einem Platz finden
dem new African
[Musik]
shrine mit dem Fotografen Kago idebur
genannt bischop tauchen wir noch einmal
ein in die Nacht in seine Menschen und
ihre unbändige
Energie der Schrein ist die Pilgerstätte
für die Fans von felakuti dem gotfather
des afrobits seine Musikwelt berühmt
sein Leben und sein Tod
legendär wer hier abfeiern will braucht
nicht viel Geld einllar kostet der
Eintritt niemand wird
abgewiesen für bisch
na ein fllhorn an Motiven und für seinen
Freund den und Maler Volum auch eine
Inspiration für mich ist der Schrein der
Magneten
Lagos wenn du als Besucher nicht im
Schrein warst dann warst du nicht in
Lagos tagsüber ist der Schrein wie eine
Blaser
Mens
Musik aber nachts siehst du das Feuer
das
Leben und das ist wirklich Lagos nachts
brennt hier ein anderes
Feuer ein Feuer das nie erlischt die
Menschen in der meity Lagos brennen für
das Leben egal wie oder jung egal wie
reich oder arm es gibt keinen Stillstand
in der Stadt der
[Musik]
Extreme